test test test so last week I finished
my book super excited it's off to the
publisher historic moment for me filming
it at the starbucks the very first
starbucks and you know i was hoping to
create something just as historic the
very first artwork was created there the
very first I haven't kind like a book
was film there so now I figure what I do
this week and I were thinking back to a
video that I watched from gene Simmons
his top ten rules for success and in one
of the clips he's talking about Steven
Spielberg and Steven Spielberg the most
successful you know director of all time
everything he touches it seems to turn
the gold and it's not by accident right
he has a formula it doesn't just
accidentally turn out hit after hit
after hit after hit and I'm wondering
can I apply those lessons from Spielberg
to my book to turn out my first hit and
what he does has the sword gozes
whenever he finishes a movie before he
shows us the general public he does a
screening he does a test with a test
audience and he goes to some no-name
town from small town and shows it to the
people there and as gene Simmons says
these people are in no position to judge
him or give him feedback some of them
may not be regular moviegoers and here
you are giving feedback to Steven
Spielberg the greatest director of all
time and the reason why he does that is
because he wants his films appeal to
everybody not just appeal to a certain
segment of the population but to
everybody and so that's what he does he
goes and does a test market Cesar de
action is and then makes any edits or
cuts as needed based on how people react
and so I'm at the situation now with my
book where it's too long it's it's a lot
too long a lot of pages too long and I
said it to my editor and she's reviewing
it she hasn't given me feedback yet at
the publishing house and I'm at the
situation where it's either broken down
into multiple books or are sections are
cut out and I use them as bonus chapters
or other premium content or we'll see
we'll see what I do with it but I don't
want just her to be editing it so the
plan right now is instead of going to
walk into whole foods to write I'm going
to go
and print off 20 to 25 copies of my
original manuscript and share it with
people in my circle and I'm going to get
their feedback on it what I'm asking to
do is basically spend 10 hours in the
next two weeks reading it reviewing it
giving feedback and I don't care so much
about what they think about the content
in terms of writing style or anything
like that because I'm comfortable with
the riding sound comfortable with the
content itself what I'm what I'm curious
about is I'm going to give them printed
physical copies and I want to see what
they highlight I'm going to take the
copies back I want to see what they
highlight where they've written notes on
the side where they feel like these
pages are applicable to their lives and
their business some of their
entrepreneurs some of them are
entrepreneurs and well why am i giving a
book for entrepreneurs to bunch of none
entrepreneurs because I think it can
still apply I want to be able to reach a
wide segment of the audience and I think
everybody has that idea that they want
to turn into a business right
everybody's I want to be entrepreneurs
or not an entrepreneur already and so I
think it's actually super helpful at the
start I was questioning whom they will
only want to give it to entrepreneurs or
not but I think it's super helpful to
give it to people who haven't started a
business yet and so the plan is give it
to them see what they highlight see what
they write in the comments just for
themselves like not feedback for me just
read it like it would be a book for you
how you would mark it up just for
yourself and then take all the
manuscripts back and see which pages got
the most highlights got the most
comments most you know underlines and
notes on the side and those are the
pages I have to keep right those are the
pages that are getting the most
engagement and the ones that don't get
as much I can potentially pull those and
turn into something else for the
hardcore people and it also gives me
leverage so if I'm you know fighting
with my editor at the publishing house
which has it started so hopefully I'll
be smooth process but just in case I do
I've got this backup of all these people
who reviewed it and say no this page
needs to stay look at all the engage
that we gone and look how much people
love it we have to keep that page today
my goal is a print off 20 to 25 versions
of this manuscript my final book and
then connect with people who I think
would be good people to read it and
deliver that to them this week I'm so
excited I'm so excited to get this out
to the world I can't tell you guys it's
been a long process I mean really been
join along with me throughout my journey
but I'm so excited to get this out and
hopefully in the coming weeks we'll have
updates for you
on how everything's going normally at
this time I do Q&A I know there's a
couple questions that came in it is way
too cold for me to pull out the the ipad
air my phone here and look at questions
for you so once i get indoors i will
promise I'll make some video responses
for you guys so i'm over at alex's place
excited to release my book to the world
and you may be some coffee i said no
initially but then itself subjectively
has irish cream happening here so it's
so good with Bailey's man anyway no not
having Bailey's so i'm having a large
cup of coffee there with two milks and
one sugar I feel like more could go in
the cup I feel like you kind of cheap
enough in the coffee like look at all
that space and take it to the rim oh you
like Alex how its hospitality drop it
off that's how much you appreciate that
coffee Evan that's it that's a
compliment that's a compliment right
right to the tippy there you go look at
that that's what I'm talking about
that's an appreciation and alex is using
the mug that i got in from seattle which
is the very first from the very first
starbucks ever created I know this much
he insisted that i buy it for himself I
was gonna buy anything for him to be
honest but then you said that's not I
had together at least at least I notice
appreciate it too now I feel good this
is life of an entrepreneur okay is my
own thank you for this walk ever I
learned about the lumina characters
after the publisher and I wanted to know
if it helps you or not to use new words
I mean how do you deal with it putting
your ideas are using new concepts of
words explaining idea completely I'm not
totally understanding this question I
feel like he suggested I use shorter
words or new words instead of longer
words anyway I mean I feel like I dress
this at the at the opening of how I'm
going to be cutting it down either one
cut into multiple books or to cut out
sections and that's why I'm doing the
feedback from the people to see you what
do you really like and what they don't
like as much there might be fooled into
something else mono purty hi everyone
would be possibly get a signed copy of
your book when I place my order and your
agent or publisher arrange a system
we're buying everyone who pre-orders the
book receives an autographed copy with a
personal message I don't know if this
would be feasible but that would be
worthwhile asking prior to your
marketing call I have no idea if that's
possible how that works
I'm totally open to it I do love
personalizing things depends on how many
you guys are pretty hard here in my next
video might be just Evan signing books
but thank you for the idea i'll pass it
on and i'll see again i have no idea
what that process looks like but as I
learned more i'll keep you guys posted
the cookies room eager to read your book
if you need help to share it translate
it in French please let me know a funny
French entrepreneur is following you and
love what you do thank you for pushing
us peace take in the cookies room you
know another one of these questions I
have no idea what's going to happen in
terms of the the marketing and the
translation and when it will be
multilingual when will hit different
countries but I promise you just like
the last question as I learned more i'll
keep you guys posted and the feedback is
great because i can forward that on to
my publisher and say hey these guys want
it we got to give it to them let's find
a way to make it happen so a little bit
of behind the scenes for you guys what
I've been doing is ruin everything in
Google Docs initially started in Word
and then it was too hard to share with
my team to review and look at so we
moved to Google Docs and we did each
chapter is its own doctor into Google
Docs I was going to show you it I was
going to show you the google doc but
then realize that the title is there and
there's some information there that i'm
not allowed to show you guys yet so what
it's coming it's coming but in terms of
picking the the people that are going to
review have review my book last week i
posted on my facebook is my personal
facebook a picture of me at starbucks
saying that i finished the book what
does it say 100 plus people liked it and
then a bunch of people left comment
saying they were looking forward to it a
bunch of stuff so these are gonna be the
people that I reach out to first to see
if they want to review it and get some
feedback and again a mix of
entrepreneurs and non entrepreneurs and
I am super excited to release it into
the world so I'm going to cut it there
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know what you think of my process
leave it in comments below I'd also love
to know if you guys have questions about
my book about the book writing process
leave in comment and i will make a video
see you next week okay that's it thank
you guys for watching it seem to believe
and i'll see you soon
you